[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de reporteros aquí en france24 soy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos la crisis de kobe 19 en
francia ha movilizado o vuelto a
movilizar los hospitales en guadalupe
desde el mes de marzo y la ausencia de
infraestructuras médicas y de personal
nunca había sido tan problemática una
combinación de dos factores que hace que
la crisis en la isla sea más intensa que
en otros territorios franceses uno es la
falta de camas y de personal en el
centro hospitalario universitario y el
otro el deteriorado sistema de
distribución de agua los guadalupenses
viven la pandemia asediados por dos
temores no poder ser atendidos y no
poder respetar las medidas para evitar
el contagio el tercer problema es
económico el turismo es un pilar de la
economía en guadalupe esencial para el
empleo en la región y la crisis de kobe
19 afectó decenas de empresas de las
cuales algunas se vieron obligadas a
cerrar definitivamente sus puertas esta
es la historia
[Música]
se me idea de agua
quedarme
lo voy a jalar señor cayo' cierre la
mano cierre la una última vez está bien
señor cayo' vamos a ponerlo de costado
además de los cuidados técnicos hay que
tener cuidados relacionales que no
siempre se tienen incluso aunque a veces
los pacientes estén en coma a mí me
gusta recomendar que se mantenga la
conversación para volver a situar un
poco al paciente en el tiempo en
realidad nosotros somos el vínculo entre
el exterior y ellos además de sus
familiares cuando vienen a visitarlos
guadalupe atraviesa una crisis sin
precedentes
es que me sabe mal
no da con el servicio de reanimación del
centro hospitalario universitario de
cuánta pasó el pico de la segunda
ola de kobe 19 pero sigue alerta el día
de la filmación de las 29 camas de
reanimación disponibles 28 están
ocupadas hoy como ocurre a menudo la
dificultad está relacionada con el lugar
la geografía de la isla es un obstáculo
considerable para el acceso al cuidado
es posible que el paciente de sandra
acta no lo podamos recibir porque el
helicóptero no podrá despegar así con el
clima eso era seguro estamos en alerta
naranja y es un paciente que solo puede
ser transportado en helicóptero y con
estas condiciones meteorológicas el
helicóptero no puede despegar eso
complica el acceso al cuidado para los
que están en las islas en particular en
madrid aland y sants y sant acta que son
dependencias de guadalupe son
situaciones que ocurren todo el año es
una consecuencia de nuestra situación
insular no tenemos la suerte de estar en
una metrópolis y tener un centro
hospitalario a 50 km que pueda tomar el
relevo en caso de fallo realmente
dependemos de los medios detrás
de aire
alerta naranja fuerte en lluvias vientos
violentos y entonces imposibilidad para
viajar
el centro hospitalario universitario a
menudo debe reubicar pacientes a veces
por falta de recursos fundamentales no
tenemos un cirujano cardíaco en
guadalupe o cirugía cardiaca se hace en
martinica entonces nuestros pacientes de
guadalupe que necesitan un sm o son
pacientes que deben ser transportados a
martinica nueva alerta al mediodía el
estado de uno de los pacientes atendidos
en las urgencias por covite empeora debe
ser llevado a reanimación el problema
la última cama que queda está dañada en
este caso es necesario verificar el
personal no estaba al tanto de la cama
estaba dañada no hay cama la cama está
dañada hace 3 o 4 semanas que la cama
está dañada y al parecer nadie lo había
reportado el último lugar en el servicio
es ocupado por un hombre de 39 años
deportista él no lo entiende
entre las urgencias de kobe ya tenía un
dolor en el costado derecho
sospecharon que era un cólico nefrítico
así que me llevaron a las otras
urgencias y no encontrarse nada entonces
pensé que todo estaba mejor pensé que
pasaría y una semana después caída en
picada no me esperaba para nada que eso
me cayera encima hago deporte todo el
tiempo hago deporte mi novia no tiene
ningún síntoma es tóxica
en el momento más duro de la crisis la
reserva sanitaria equipos de personal
médico enviados por parís permitió
mantener disponibles las escasas 44
camas de reanimación para un territorio
que tiene más de 400.000 habitantes
[Música]
para compensar la falta de personal
varias unidades médicas tuvieron que
cerrar y volver a abrir por turnos
actualmente por falta de espacio todavía
debe utilizarse en la cafetería del
hospital para recibir a los pacientes
que no tienen como 19 en guadalupe no
hay segundo confinamiento a pesar de las
peticiones del personal médico los
habitantes han mantenido mucha libertad
para circular
pero la aplicación de gestos barreras se
enfrenta a otro problema el agua
en la isla no faltan las precipitaciones
pero su sistema de distribución
deteriorado deja escapar más del 60% de
esa agua hacia los suelos todo el
territorio está afectado es una falta
vital en plena pandemia
pero si hace casi dos meses que
realmente no hay nada pero realmente ni
una gota ni un chorro absolutamente nada
y es complicado los días son difíciles
bañar a los niños es un problema lavar
los platos de es un problema el baño es
un problema led y sobre todo ahora en
épocas del coi 19 donde hay que lavarse
con frecuencia las manos ahí se vuelve
insoportable
es una situación que ha durado 10 años
actualmente los gestos barreras se
aplican con muy poca regularidad
hace años y años que existe este
problema aquí en google
para conseguir algunas botellas ya va a
casa de su hermano es agotador sobre
todo después de una jornada de trabajo
hay que salir de trabajar recoger a los
niños en el colegio hacer las tareas y
luego volver a salir para ir a por agua
es extenuante
[Aplausos]
[Música]
voy a tener que pagar sí porque están
todas estas botellas por llenar y todo
esto okay está bien un poco menos caro
que para la ciudad al menos sí sí sí al
menos bueno porque a la larga
aquí está su agua muchas gracias muy
amable le envío la factura la factura
ok entonces hasta mañana hasta mañana
desde el surgimiento de los problemas de
agua en guadalupe se han formado varias
asociaciones todas exigen la aceleración
de los trabajos de renovación
cómo podemos enfrentar todo esto cuando
estamos obligados a desplazarnos a ir
por agua a la casa de un pariente ay por
agua a una cisterna pública a las
fuentes donde todo el mundo va y viene
cómo podemos respetar realmente esos
gastos barreras
acabamos de hablar sobre la incoherencia
de esta situación es decir que la medida
más importante en el gesto barrera es la
que no está asegurada si no hay
respuesta llevaremos estas exigencias
ante el nivel más alto del estado para
que nos dé una respuesta los ciudadanos
de google y de manera general de
guadalupe no son sus ciudadanos hay un
daño senegal no one nube no son para de
su sitúa ya en este punto la isla está
ante un callejón sin salida en las tres
cuartas partes del territorio más de la
mitad del agua potable se pierde en
cuanto a los trabajos por lo general
están atrasados la asociación calcula
que una renovación completa costaría
entre 1 y 1.5 mil millones
por su parte los poderes públicos han
invertido casi 94 millones de euros
desde 2014 en varios planes operativos
de reparación y de saneamiento
para muchos un monto irrisorio ante la
multiplicación de los cortes nos
encontramos con y en su casa en su
primer día de descanso de la semana
después de cinco días de 12 horas de
trabajo es la única enfermera del
servicio de reanimación que recopila
datos sobre la enfermedad el objetivo es
detectar las especificidades en el
desarrollo del virus en guadalupe y
asegurar el vínculo con la metrópolis
desde el comienzo de la crisis ha tenido
que estudiar el kobe 19 en su tiempo
libre
me resultó muy difícil pensar que me
encerraría en una oficina mientras mis
colegas les hacía falta personal para
las camas de los pacientes si no lo hago
hoy habría tenido que hacerlo en dos
meses sabiendo que tendría que recuperar
dos meses de datos lo cual sería mucho
más larga sin pasión de su casa cansa
porque realmente no interrumpo el
trabajo en 14 años de reanimación es la
primera vez que he tenido ganas de parar
ya pasó pero realmente tuve ganas de
parar en un momento
la falta de recursos va más allá del
sector sanitario los pilares económicos
de guadalupe también están afectados el
turismo una de las principales riquezas
de la economía de la isla sufre
en 2019 los visitantes gastaron 728
millones de euros en el departamento las
previsiones para el 2020 anuncian una
disminución casi del 70% la crisis del
hobby 19 deja las plazas de mercado las
marinas y los hoteles vacíos un freno
terrible para quienes dependen de ello
de tanto que el barco no sale ya no
funciona no tiene voltaje no tiene
batería de un barco que no sale es un
barco que no se utiliza no hay clientes
no hay excursiones
no hay baterías el barco está abandonado
la marina el seguro todo el resto si uno
no tiene cuarenta mil euros para pagar
todo eso no puede aguantar no es posible
montt
viendo la cantidad de demandas que
tenemos aquí es realmente un 70 por
ciento menos
ha pensado vender su barco no no voy a
vender mi barco ahora cuando uno ha
pasado tanto tiempo con un barco como
éste realmente no dan ganas de venderlo
hay muchas personas que ya me lo han
preguntado yo voy a conservar mi barco
porque porque como dicen soy una mamá
gallina neopul
rudy resiste ante la crisis privado de
su principal fuente de ingresos la pesca
asegura su salario mínimo vital para
otros la ausencia de turistas este año
fue fatal
yang gerente hotelera también combina
varias actividades pero sólo pasará unas
semanas en sanando
bits y rica
con la crisis del cob y de 19 es verdad
que hacer masajes tener esa actividad no
ha permitido sobrevivir actualmente mi
principal actividad son los masajes
porque ya no tengo clientes en el hotel
los propietarios del lugar mantienen un
alquiler de seis mil quinientos euros
mensuales
la gerente no tiene opción debe regresar
a francia
y poco a poco las reservas que se
cancelaron la proyección es que todo se
reactivará a nivel económico en
guadalupe hacia noviembre de 2021
entonces yo no puedo aguantar hasta
noviembre de 2021 desde un punto de
vista económico desde un punto de vista
de tesorería sobre una salida obligada
como muchas otras ni las ayudas a las
empresas ni el préstamo garantizado por
el estado le permitirá conservar su
negocio
va a ser difícil irme porque estoy aquí
hace 11 años y estoy bien aquí es un
lugar excepcional que ame que ame
profundamente y ahora de repente esto va
a ser difícil un gran quiebre
[Música]
guasave
difícil en esta aplicación
[Música]
hasta aquí esta emisión de reporteros
recuerde que puede repetir este y otros
documentales en nuestra web france24
puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]